>> Hi Zennie I really loved your video and
I would like to respond to it because , I
sort of feel about it in the same way.
I worked for a lot of refugees in London and
I think that one of the greatest problems
that we have is our difficulties
in receiving and tolerating anyone who's different
from ourselves. We have so many boundaries
in the world and I think
that one of the only ways that we can start
to mount those boundaries by really talking
to each other. We need to listen to
each other's stories. That's the bottom line
really and art and culture can help with that
a great deal, but we also need to
encourage you know businesses and politicians
to listen in a slightly different way. There
was this young kid from China on
my session yesterday who said "you know the
politicians need to use their ears as something
other than just operations on the
side of their head" and I just thought that
was brilliant. So I heard you and I'm working
very hard myself to mount those
strange walls that we put up between each
other and I think that that kind of work can
be done on the ground, every day, just
by turning around to someone who looks different
to you and saying hello what's your story.